[Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  don't stay awake for too long  don't go to bed and make a cup of coffee  for your head i'll  [Music]  and i promise that one day i'll  feel all right  and i'll make a cup of coffee with the  right amount of sugar how you like  it and i'll make a cup of coffee  with the right amount of sugar how you  like  it how you like it  don't know how long i'll stay for  it's okay i'm gonna come your  door won't you come down and get me  i'd like you when you hold me tight  it makes me feel nice  and green in your eyes  makes me feel inside  and i'll make a cup of coffee the right  amount of sugar how you like it  and i'll make a cup of coffee with the  right amount of sugar  [Music]  was that a cow  [Laughter]  nice ambience  do  you